le département de la Vienne se conjugue
au pluriel et se vit dans le collectif
alors permettez-moi de remercier
chaleureusement l'ensemble des
conseillers et départementaux engagés à
mes côtés depuis le début de ce mandat
s'engager pour la mienne c'est une
attention particulière portée au plus
fragile accueillir et protéger les
enfants en détresse accompagner les
familles permettre à nos aînés de
vieillir dignement apporter des
solutions concrètes aux personnes
souffrant d'un handicap mettre en
sécurité les victimes de violence aider
les personnes éloignées de l'emploi à
retrouver le chemin de la confiance et
du travail pour cette nouvelle année je
veux partager avec vous trois
convictions la première c'est que nous
trouvons les solutions aux crises
actuelles dans le dialogue et en
demeurant un territoire unique
c'est une voix difficile exigeante et
dans ces temps agité le rassemblement
des bonnes volontés mais pas une option
c'est une nécessité la deuxième c'est le
besoin impérieux de proximité c'est ma
conviction profonde sans proximité il
n'y a pas de confiance
et sur le départemental en est la plus
belle des représentations avec les
communes et les élus basent de notre
démocratie la dernière c'est que pour
accomplir de grandes choses il faut
sortir de la politique des certitudes
pour bâtir une politique de projet une
politique du bon sens je ne conçois pas
l'action publique autrement pour résumer
s'il était aveu que je souhaiterais voir
s'accomplir en 2023 pour la Vienne ce
serait celui de continuer tous ensemble
à servir encore plus fortement notre
département pour surmonter des crises
d'aujourd'hui
et les épreuves de demain regardons loin
pour agir proche ce département pour
lequel on aime vivre et qui grandit
chaque jour un peu plus grâce à sa
jeunesse ses élus ces associations ces
chefs d'entreprise c'est sportif grâce à
tous ceux qui assurent notre sécurité
grâce à ses savoir-faire ces traditions
ses talents ces projets ces innovations
très belle année à toutes et à tous
merci
[Applaudissements]